[Música]
eu fui chamado aqui porque eu queria
esse negócio meio maluco são pequenas
casas compartilhadas e demorou muito
para entender o que elas realmente eram
e demorou cerca de três anos ela a
primeira casa completa três anos agora
os 27 de outubro
só que assim foi um crescimento
assustador ao mesmo tempo imagino que
pequenos espaços compartilhados num
terreno não tão fácil quanto o brasil em
meio à crise não parecia o melhor dos
cenários e de repente é descobrir sem
querer que a house of food era o
primeiro a restaurante compartilhado do
mundo o que a gente tem de fato um
restaurante que todos os dias a gente
tem um chefe diferente
eles alugam minha cozinha cozinha e
ganham dinheiro deles próprios chefes é
uma grande oportunidade de testá di
saber se aquilo que eles querem mesmo
para os clientes é a grande oportunidade
de experimentar a comida fresca porque
imagina todos os dias o chef chico com
os ingredientes frescos
eles preparam todo aquele dia entregam
então eu garanto pra você sempre vai
comer uma comida com preço justo de um
chefe dependente e com alta qualidade e
acredito que tenha sido por isso que fui
convidado mas no final das contas é é um
pouco mais que isso o que todas essas
casas se tornaram pra mim e acabaram se
tornando para a comunidade que eu atendo
mais legal começar explicando por que
por que tudo isso começou
começou lá atrás quando eu ainda era
casado em uma startup tendência às vezes
você perde um casamento é nas era casado
e sempre tive essa ânsia de compartilhar
coisas então eu não via por que eu tinha
que morar num apartamento só meu era um
diretor de criação tinha um certo
sucesso profissional financeiro mas eu
dividia com amigos porque morava num
apartamento grande falar porque não
e como sempre tinha um quarto extra
sobrando hospedava amigos do brasil
inteiro e até do mundo
então recebi dos meus amigos cariocas os
meus amigos de brasília de porto alegre
enfim todo mundo ficava em casa já era
conhecido como ruby e daí uma amiga
minha que questionou no facebook uma vez
balançar eu tenho um amigo que vai
precisar de um lugar para ficar no
brasil durante três meses que ele tem um
estágio de verão ele está fazendo mba
aqui comigo pra paulinha pode ficar aqui
mandei pra cá e simplesmente pra mim era
normal hospedar pessoas e quando eu
contei isso cheguei à noite aquele
esquema de casal chega em casa escutando
jamor é vai ficar um amigo da paulo
prates vai fazer um estágio de verão vai
ficar dois meses aqui
nossa nunca vi ela tão irada como você
coloca um estranho dentro da nossa casa
sem me consultar
eu falei nossa como não pode cancelar
isso ele não vem e depois acho que uma
das vezes em uma das poucas vezes que
não teve nenhum argumento for assim não
vou fazer isso eu não vou voltar atrás
porque esse cara tá vindo de outro lugar
do mundo
ele não tem certeza nenhuma ele não sabe
para onde vai não sabe o que tem
eles imaginam que a gente vive na cidade
de deus ou então dentro da floresta
amazônica e eu estou dando alguma
garantia para esse cara ele vai ficar
aqui e esse foi um pouco difícil imagina
eu não sofri um pouco algumas semanas
acabou de chegar mas finalmente o grupo
chegou e eu esperei o brasil era o cara
que o horário flexível tudo mais breve
entra em casa sair
liguei pra ela foi o bate é muito legal
você vai adorar ele e ela falou no
telefone você coloca um estranho dentro
da minha casa e tudo que você tem pra
falar sobre ele é legal ver o meu filho
e daí eu falei não tá eu vou escrever
vou tentar ser o mais racional possível
o bright ele é alto
ele é nosso é bem alto e ele é
ele é forte rapaz esse cara quiser me
bater tudo soterrado mas só meio
estranho mas já que foi apresentado como
o campineiro talvez não tão estranha
o brett ele é o cara mais bonito que já
vi pessoalmente é é ele também ele faz o
órgão business school na pensilvânia
super disputado por todo mundo no mundo
inteiro e ele ele entrou ele não é bom
se ele paga e ele falou que a gente pode
ficar na casa dele em nova york ele mora
a duas quadras do central park e se a
gente quiser tirar férias também na
itália a família dele tem uma casa na
toscana
o resumo é ele é grande forte bonito
rico e inteligente
por que diabos o que esse cara dois
metros o que aconteceu de fato foi isso
bate a ficar dois meses lá e acabou
ficando seis meses no brasil
a gente se chama de irmão até hoje ele
virou um irmão é obviamente a minha
esposa ela continua minha amiga também
mas ela adoro brad também não tem como
não gostar do bate porque além de tudo
não falei bate ainda falar em sete
idiomas ea gente boa não sei cara
alguma coisa tem errado ali e o que
acontece de fato aquilo foi a primeira
experiência que eu pude provar pra minha
esposa na época que eu não superava a
estranhos
eles eram futuros amigos e assim foi que
eu comecei a hospedar pessoas no morumbi
depois daquilo mas aquele primeiro passo
com brad determinou tudo que era
compartilhar pra mim é um jeito que eu
faço onde sempre que eu divido eu não
abro mão de nada eu só ganho e todo
mundo dividindo comecei a ver os ganhos
sobre ganho sobre ganho eo as casas
foram resultado onde consegui colocar
parte sustentável dentro daquilo porque
o que ele falou ali também no vídeo
passado é sustentabilidade tem a ver com
se sustentar
então eu tinha que fazer aquilo o que
acontece é que depois ainda ficou um
pouco pior
depois de alguns meses o brest perdeu o
pai dele e eu que já era órfão liguei
pra ele fred está tudo bem você precisa
de alguma coisa ele falou pra mim
telefone não agora tudo o que precisa
ficar com
a família dele não claro entendo ele
falou não é sério meu quarto tatoo
disponível
estou comprando uma passagem precisa
ficar com a minha família essa história
do grande
essa é uma história sobre compartilhar é
impossível você não ganhar se você é
entrar mesmo nisso e o intuito todo o
que eu falei que demorou três anos para
entender exatamente o que eu fazia isso
eu ofereço mais acesso no lugar de posse
e quando você fala isso parece uma coisa
meio distante mas todo mundo aqui já
está acostumado com o netflix
enquanto as pessoas aqui antes tinham
compravam dvds os seus preferidos
você não precisa mais disso você não
precisa ter coisas só quer ter acesso a
ela você quer assistir um filme você não
precisa comprar o filme quer furar a
parede de uma furadeira sabe uma coisa e
quando eu cheguei no cenário comida
ficou muito mais claro ainda que a coisa
mais barata do que você fala nossa
acabou açúcar se bate no seu vizinho o
vizinho açúcar
obrigado depois de voar quando você
precisar a que o óleo óleo ovo empresto
liquidificador que você precisa ter
batedeira nossa minha avó nunca teve
batedeira lembro de um pequeno assim
correndo pegando batedeira da vizinha
para fazer bolo pra mim então não é uma
coisa simples ea gente precisa resgatar
essas coisas e quando falo de
descentralização é o fato de você
descentraliza posse de trás vários
ganhos e eu trouxe um exemplo aqui de
algumas coisas que a gente resolver
relatório falando exatamente sobre
comida eu tenho o prazer de trabalhar
com pessoas bem interessantes porque
dentro dessa casa ainda é um corpo em
meio diferente mas é um coloque então eu
tenho um pessoal de indígenas fizeram um
relatório para a onu sobre a fome zero
para chegar à fome zero e dentro da
palavra de boquim e eu falei que nossa
não tem introdução bloco tinha como vou
explicar o que tinha pra vocês
bom ele explicou ali sobre a rede como
vai fazer uma rede compartilhada adora
então resolveu todo o problema antes não
precisa explicar para vocês o que
blocking e aqui falando um pouco do que
eu acredito sobre o futuro compartilhado
da comida que é uma coisa que eu tô com
foco muito grande em fazer agora o
futuro compartilhada como insetos
já faz lá quem é este o chefe esteve
também já sabe do lance dele com a
formiga e ele mesmo já falou pra mim e
falar é incerto como nutriente dá pra
falar que em certa comida mas assim
inseto é comido um monte de lugar e daí
o fato de você compartilhar é o espaço
faz insetos é uma coisa para você pensar
no futuro e falo de compartilhamento de
espaço porque tem um dado alarmante por
isso é esse é um dos motivos também que
entre nesse lance de economia
compartilhada
se a gente continuar consumindo mesmo
que a gente consome hoje em 2050 a gente
vai precisar de dois planetas para dar
conta do que a gente consome ou seja não
tem jeito então é uma modinha estilo
marketing que você vai falar assim
colocar um selo de empresa sustentável
as empresas estão realmente preocupadas
porque se elas continuarem fazendo o que
elas fazem elas não vão ter como fazer
ela já sabem disso isso é um dado aberto
outra coisa muito interessante muito
legal são as comidas de segunda mão
quando se pensa em comida segundo a moça
falou assim nossa é lixo
sim é lixo no futuro a gente não pode
ter lixo gente a gente tem que
compartilhar a comida seu extremo não
ter lixo
só que nesse caso já tem vários com
várias coisas acontecendo no mundo tem
um negócio chamado angle food que
começou na frança que são comidas cheias
você vai ao supermercado tem isso então
tudo bonitinho né
você já imaginou que não nasce tudo
bonitinho tem várias que são fez o que
eles fazem com as feias não vendem então
começou a ter mercado de comida feia e
isso é uma coisa que a gente vai
implementar em breve também dentro da
rosa foi vai ter um dia por semana onde
a gente quer ter mercado de comida feia
que vai ser muito legal eu recomendo que
todo mundo entre lá tudo que passou aqui
é muito legal ver isso o relatório
abordou várias tecnologias várias coisas
e várias inovações acerca de comida e de
como pode ser o futuro da comida acesse
este link e depois vocês vão poder pegar
pelo vídeo
mas lá você consegue ter é um dado
aberto foi o relatório gerado para a onu
é uma coisa muito interessante e tem
mais dados do que só isso que eu trouxe
é mas além disso qual o conceito real
dessas casas o que eu quis trazer para a
minha vida eu queria trazer é eu queria
de centralizar a informação sobre as
coisas e trazer exemplos reais sobre as
coisas porque não adianta ver que falar
e é muito legal você pegar o background
de tudo que aconteceu durante o dia aqui
e ver o pessoal falando assim cara não
venha me falar a sentar ali falou que eu
tenho que fazer venho aqui faz então é
isso que a gente faz essas casas são
casos de exemplos reais exemplo real
sobre o compartilhamento de comida
talvez seja a coisa mais banal como a
ceia de natal que todo mundo tem em casa
e isso foi uma das coisas que a gente
trouxe para dentro da da house of food
logo na criação dela a gente namorou ela
em 2014 e 2015 o jovem como idéia foi
assim não eu quero compartilhar a comida
e eu fiz da forma mais simples possível
eu peguei só coloquei um monte de mesa
na rua tinham 960 lugares para sentar e
convidei todo mundo pra falar assim
traga sua comida de casa e compartilhe
com seu vizinho ea gente vai criar uma
comunidade inteira de pessoas que
entende o que é compartilhar e vocês vão
entender que ninguém tá perdendo tanto
só todo mundo ganhando porque são os
excessos que prejudicam a gente
e nesse caso foi muito legal a gente
teve fotó rua repleta de pessoas que nem
se falavam antes trazendo e não tem
aquele lance a eu fiz o peru mas o peru
custa caro aqui na ceia com a farofa
custa barato só que o peru se coloca ele
no forno está pronto não te dar trabalho
a farofa alguém determina ali passatempo
gastar aquilo é uma energia coloca amor
naquilo isso não tem preço
quando você junta os dois está dividindo
o valor que é um valor financeiro e
lembra dinheiro só é título de dívida
está o dinheiro é um título de dívida
impresso quando outra pessoa o valor que
está em fazer criar as coisas é tudo que
a gente viu aqui é o cheiro da da
batedeira da sua avó não tem preço tem
coisas que não têm preço e quando você
coloca tudo pra dividir as pessoas só
estão felizes e elas param de das
pequenices e isso foi uma coisa que eu
vi mudar nesse tempo todo é um comum
o prazer que eu entrego depois de três
anos eu vejo no negócio crescer e se
multiplicar hoje a gente já está no rio
de janeiro e em belo horizonte também
com uma mensagem simples mais acesse -
posse para tudo e eu convido a todos que
reflitam sobre isso e que conheçam um
projeto que a gente vai lançar em breve
que a gente vai ter uma página dedicada
isso que vai ser o festival da comida do
futuro onde a gente vai colocar ali
receitinhas de como você compartilhar o
conhecimento sobre cenários futuros
mas principalmente também como você
compartilha a comida entre todos que
vocês conhecem familiares bairros
cidades porque o meu intuito é comecei
ali pequenino uma casinha
cresci por uma rua inteira que atinge eu
vou conseguir fazer um bairro
eu já consegui uma cidade inteira
mobilizada e quem sabe não mobilizar o
país inteiro para que todos entendam que
a gente tem
primeiro uma inovação brasileira feito
por brasileiro com um direcionamento
muito genuíno com propósito pra fazer a
vida de todo mundo melhor e da forma
mais simples possível
só emprestando açúcar só compartilhando
a vida então obrigado
[Aplausos]